[Musique]
je vais appeler les deux qui vont jouer
et je vais vous montrer les titres que
vous allez devoir trouver alors si je
retrouve mes fiches on est dans une
merde noire
les achats clément joly attention jean
michel vous allez devoir faire découvrir
à cette équipe
d'accord c'est très simple ça pue
l'électrocution en direct le prendre
chez sud vous mettez vous mettez la télé
dans l'eau vous devez il va il va
chanter vous devez chanter que quand
vous êtes sous l'eau vous étiez trouve
également chez vous ok cette équipe qui
joue d'accord et qui chante la chanson
en entier les chéris admirer en
allégeant michel ils doivent chanter
dans les deux sens et pas en 10 secondes
n'a eu droit qu'à une seule propose
d'aller au concert pour faire attention
c'est parti
jean-michel trois deux un premier titre
chantons sous la flotte ces partis petit
que vous avez choisi la tête dans l'eau
[Applaudissements]
autour de l'ipad n'est gratuit la balle
a dit d'amour et non pas trop et de 7 à
77 ans j'ai perdu mais mettez-vous de
côté ses pairs du bassin pas mieux au
visage elle ces hommes elle fera pas
pire mais ça devrait bien aller voir
d'imagés
ah bon après sa cave où vient du contre
et là bas parce que c'est ce qu'on
appelle une voie d'eau impossible à
aller à lévis alors mais tu veux la gd
maquillage et cerise et anniversaire
j'espère alors au nom là cela tombe bien
ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
allez-y asie mais ça va a dit est ce
qu'on a le droit de jouer nous on joue
aussi bien sûr la noria que tu veux pas
prendre ma place parce qu'un résident et
pourrait chanter allez au long vas-y
solo
[Musique]
j'exige
[Applaudissements]
là
c'est gagné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour s'attaquer
[Applaudissements]
alors qu est ce que je fais ce que je
vous prêt à vous proposer
est-ce qu'on peut enlever l'aquarium
s'il vous plaît ce que je vous propose
des cherry ce qu'on peut faire tout de
suite parce que je vous le dis je vous
dire on n'a plus le temps donc c'est
cette équipe qui a gagné c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qu'ils soient sont pas mentir
à jésus il faut pas mentir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce qu'on fera appeler est ce qu'on
peut me dire ce que le public à gagner
si on paie pas ce que tu veux dire
c'était lors tout ça nous apporte quoi
gagner une position
[Rires]
la tension est ce qu'on peut dire ce
qu'il s'est passé alors léché avec alloc
vial et à la compil de baba yaga n'y a
pas d'autres délires de la part des
pâtes et des bijoux a well as tu
condamnes il ya quoi l'os l'aquarium ya
le c'est tout ça valait le coup
d'attendre halloween c'est aussi une
séance où ce pas
et des bracelets tous les faits et vous
avez gagné
ouais vous savez quoi je fais gagner
tout
merci